their favorite Laker of all time is
LeBron not a red flag no not at all
probably red flag huge red flag not a
real Lakers fan they have a Kobe tattoo
not a red not a red flag always a green
flag L your family forever that's a red
flag they don't follow Austin Reeves on
Instagram not a red FL red flag if you
follow kuso still you're chill red flag
100% big red flag they've never seen a
Jack Nicholson movie red flag red flag
that's a red flag that's D Nicholson
yeah but he's pretty old too they yell
Kobe every time they throw out a piece
of trash Oh flag green flag every time
if you don't do that it's 100% a red
flag green flag oh that's green flag boy
that's good they own a kame brown Lakers
jersey not a red flag at all that's the
best flag you absolutely fantastic
that's great they play pickup basketball
on a Kobe jersey not a red flag can't be
that's a green flag why not oh green
flag for show they want to trade for
Zack LaVine not a red flag why not yeah
green flag oh green flag cuz I do that's
a red flag red flag they became a fan
when LeBron joined the team oh my God
huge red flag huge red flag red flag